in the last video we did a couple of
lattice multiplication problems and you
saw it was pretty straightforward you
got to do all your multiplication first
and then do all of your addition but
let's try to understand why exactly it
worked it almost seemed like magic and
to see why it worked i'm going to redo
this problem up here and then also try
to explain what we did in the longer
problem so when we multiplied 27 so you
write your 2 and your 7 just like that
times 48
i'm just doing exactly what we did in
the previous video we drew a lattice we
gave the two a column and the seven a
column
just like that
we gave the four row and we gave the
eight a row
and then we drew our diagonal and the
key here is the diagonals you can
imagine otherwise we wouldn't be drawing
them
so you have your diagonals now the way
to think about it is each of these
diagonals are a number place so for
example this diagonal right here
that is the ones place
that is the ones place the next diagonal
i'll do it in this light green color
the next diagonal right here in the
light green color that is the tens place
now the next diagonal to the left or
above that depending on how you want to
view it i'll do it in this little pink
color
right here you could guess that's going
to be
the hundreds place
and then finally we have this little
diagonal there and i'll do it in this
light blue color
that
is the thousands place
is the thousands place so whenever we
multiply one digit times another digit
we just make sure we put it in the right
bucket or in the right place and you'll
see what i mean in a second
so we did 7 times 4 well we know what 7
times 4 is 28 we just simply wrote a 2
and an 8 just like that but what did we
really do and i guess the best way to
think about it this 7 this is the 7 and
27 so it's just a regular 7 right it's
just a regular 7 but this 4
it's the 4 and 48 so it's not just a
regular 4. it's really a 40 right 48 can
be rewritten as
forty plus eight this four right here
actually represents a forty so right
here we're not really multiplying seven
times four we're actually multiplying
seven times forty and seven
times 40 isn't just 28 it's 280.
and 280 how can we think about that we
could say that's two hundreds
two hundreds
plus eight tens
and that's exactly what we wrote right
here notice
this column or sorry this diagonal
this diagonal right here i already told
you it was the tens diagonal and we
multiplied 7 times 40. we put the 8
right here in the tens diagonal so that
means 8 tens
7 times 40 is 2 hundreds we wrote a 2 in
the hundreds diagonal and 8 tens that's
what the 2 8 here is we actually wrote
280. let's keep going when i multiply 2
times 4 you might say oh 2 times 4
that's 8. what am i really doing this is
the 2 and 27. this is really a 20 and
this is really a 40. so 20 times 40
20 times 40
is equal to
just eight with two zeros is equal to
eight hundred and what did we do we
multiplied two times four and we said oh
two times 4 is 8. we wrote a 0 and an 8
just like that but notice where we wrote
the 8 we wrote the 8 in the hundreds in
the hundreds diagonal make this a
different color we wrote it in the
hundreds diagonal so we literally wrote
even though it looked like we multiplied
2 times 4 and saying it's 8 the way we
accounted for it we really did 20 times
40 is equal to 8 hundreds remember this
is the hundreds diagonal this whole
thing right there now we can keep going
when you multiply seven times eight
remember this is really seven well this
is the seven and twenty seven so it's
just a regular seven this is the eight
and forty eight so it's just a regular
eight seven times eight is fifty six you
write a six in the ones place 56 is just
5 tens and 1 6. so it's 5
tens in the tens diagonal and 1 6 56 and
then when you multiply 2 times 8 notice
that's not really just 2 times 8 i mean
we did write it's just 16 when we did
the problem over here but we're actually
multiplying 20. this is a 20 times 8. 20
times 8
is equal to 160. or you could say it's
100 notice the 1 in the hundreds
diagonal
and 6 tens that's what 160 is so what we
did by doing this lattice multiplication
is we accounted all of the digits the
right digits in the right places we put
the six in the ones place we put the six
the five and the eight in the tens place
we put the one the eight and the two in
the hundreds place and we put nothing
right now in the thousands place then
now that we're done with all the
multiplication we can actually do our
adding up
and then you just keep adding and if
there's something that goes over to the
next place you just carry that number so
six in the ones place well that's just a
six then you go to the tens place eight
plus five plus six
is what eight plus five is 13 plus 6 is
19. but notice we're in the tens place
it's 19 tens or we could say it's nine
tens
and 100 and we carry the one up here if
you can see it into the hundreds place
then we have now we add up all the
hundreds is 100 plus 200 plus 800 plus
100 or what is this 1200 so you write 2
in the hundreds place 1200 is the same
thing as 200s plus one thousand and now
you only have one thousand and your
thousands diagonal and so you write that
one right there and that's exactly how
we did it and
the the same reasoning applies to the
more complex problem
we can label our places this was the
ones place right there
that was the ones and it made sense when
we multiplied the nine times the seven
those are just literally nines and
sevens it's 63
six tens and three ones this right here
is the tens diagonal
then we got six tens and three ones when
we multiplied
nine times eighty remember 787 that's
the same thing as seven hundreds plus
eight tens plus seven just regular seven
ones so this nine times eight is really
nine times eighty nine times eighty is
seven hundred and twenty
seven hundreds this is the hundreds
place
seven hundreds and twenty two tens two
tens just right there and you can keep
going this up here this is the thousands
place
this is the ten thousands
i'll write it like that this is the
hundred thousands place
hundred thousands and then this was the
millions place
this was the millions place so we did
all of our multiplication at once
accounted for things in their proper
place based on what those numbers really
are this caught this entry right here
you looks like we just multiplied 4
times 8 and got 32 but we actually were
multiplying 400 this is a 400 times 80
and 400
400 times 80 is equal to
three two
and three zeros is equal to thirty two
thousand and the way you we counted for
it notice we put a two
right there and what diagonal is that
that is the thousands diagonal so we see
it's two thousand and three ten
thousands so three ten thousands and two
thousands that's thirty two thousand so
hopefully that gives you an
understanding i mean it's nice that's
fun to maybe do some lattice
multiplication and get practice but you
know sometimes it looks like this
bizarre magical thing but hopefully from
this video understand that all it is is
just a different way of keeping track of
where the ones tens and hundreds place
are with the advantage that it's kind of
nice and compartmentalized doesn't take
up a lot of space
and it allows you to do all your
multiplication once and then switch your
your brain into addition and carrying
mode